how did you first uh hear about jackass
and the that we wanted to film with you
oh dude that was a story i'm at the
native village
and they go manny these jackass guys
they're really bad i mean they're really
like stupid guys they do a lot of stupid
things and they're looking for you they
want to be on their show and they got
like they're saying
some people are saying i really don't
recommend it you know i might ruin your
reputation
i come here but it's jackass guys yeah
okay yeah they're really crazy
they said you guys were dumb and crazy
and did a lot of dumb things okay
once then when i met up with you guys
finally i started to get catch on to
what's really going on
stevo's going to get ran over by an
airboat and i tell him well you got to
duck real low so you know get real low
so when airboat comes over he doesn't
hit you then i realized that stevo got
his head up high enough so the airboat
would hit it hit him in the head so i
said man i'm starting to figure out
the idea is to get the airboat to run
over here
to avoid the problem and then naxo comes
over there and um he wants to get bit by
a rattlesnake
and he wants to get bit by rattlesnake
gotta go he thought well you know just
you know take me to the hospital give me
any antivenom and we're good let's go to
the bar tonight and i said no dude that
thing bites you you might have your arm
amputated kind of like this
about that big around so
i said well that was insane and the next
thing you know sibo was going to put a
worm of his nose what do you think about
this i think it's a bad idea maybe she
cleaned the worm
because there's a lot of you know
diseases in the dirt and everything you
know we don't want to get steel sick
it's not a good idea and then and then
uh tremaine goes nah he'll put it up it
smells dirt and all
he had i think that's too it's got those
worms going through
of his nose and not his mouth like that
you know
the word but i thought i was just
cracking up you know it's just like too
much
that was the first day that we've ever
filmed with manny
and i'll never forget it we met it was a
place in the everglades where we filmed
all that yeah
and so it was this everglades like
special like tourism park
and and we're in the parking lot you
know i'll just we just arrived getting
ready to set up manny's standing there
knoxville's standing there off in the
distance this family
notices us you can see they're very
excited and they come walking over
and they i think they're gonna freak out
they think they're freaking out over
knoxville they walk right past knoxville
straight to manny manny oh it's so great
i can't even believe it i'm thinking man
like knoxville was all prepared to be
the big the big deal they walked right
past it was so funny and uh they were
all excited to see manny i thought man
manny's a really big deal
this is this is great
and and i found out later
that that
because we had filmed with sharks on the
first season and i got bitten and the
people that took us filming with those
nurse sharks were super upset and i was
like we get we need someone who's crazy
to film with and they they saw you on
animal planet and the way they described
it they said here we see this guy on
animal planet manny and he's lifting
alligators out of the water like
swimming with alligators at night riding
sharks all over the place but the fact
that he was doing all of that while
wearing a speedo
[Laughter]
they said the speedo got you the job
oh definitely
yeah after that it was just like i don't
know you guys took me to your family you
know big time manny how long were you
doing jackass before it became wild boys
like did you come on during the tv show
or during the movies the tv show came
out during the tv show and then during
the movie and then once wow boys came on
they had me on all the time
basically i got more exposure from wow
boys than anything i've ever done in my
life let's put it this way
the key for me right there yeah and like
people going wild for you at steve's
show and dani or donnie or whatever does
that happen to you often like if you go
to the grocery store or does it do you
get recognized often still to this day
yeah yeah i still got people here and
there but especially when you get you
know the right crowd you know sure i
mean i did uh shark week yeah i did
animal planet a bunch of episodes i did
outdoor channel and everything but the
huawei's was the biggest exposure like
uh 80 90 percent of people come up to me
is because i saw the wild voice it's
called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude